office seeking buffoons list their top
Tunes Politico asked the 2024
presidential candidates to name their
top 20 songs yeah leave it to Politico
to finally challenge the candidates with
some hardcore policy questions
the questionnaire asked users to make a
20-track comp which is short for
compilation cat of all your all-time
favorite tracks you know the ones that
give other people the best insight into
what stirs your soul President Biden
also listed his favorite songs but no
one could find a phonograph that played
78s
another big giant thing with the the big
cone well the results are in and they're
about as inspiring as the U.S women's
soccer team
yeah not inspiring at all in case you
missed that first up Nikki Haley is
jamming out to Joan jett's I love rock
and roll
um
she also loves War
and I'm not talking about the band The
vac Rama Swami identifies with Eminem's
Lose Yourself finally making rap no
longer cool
Hutchinson loves Levon Helms Ophelia
so yeah even his music is pulling at one
percent
[Applause]
track never heard of him by everybody
that should be his campaign slogan ever
heard of me never heard of him
ever heard God it's perfect Chris
Christie's top tracks of course Bruce
Springsteen Thunder Road well I guess
that beats Rocky Road
or thunder thighs
he's a friend
he's a friend of the show he loves our
Buffet
but we knew it was unlikely uh Chris
would identify with Born to Run but come
on Christy
I think you know you may not remember
this but Thunder Road isn't as good as
you once thought
tonight
wow
[Music]
now
almost as bad as the White Stripes
cat did we okay do you think this is
real there was this like focus group
like everything is obviously yeah okay
so this isn't all of this is kind of
embarrassing and not because it's real
but because they had people sit down and
say these are the songs that you should
pick and then then people will like you
yeah and these are the ones they chose
and my favorite thing about ASA
Hutchinson's list is that it only had
eight songs
and it said he could only provide eight
songs yes and that's funny on its own
what's even funnier is that one of them
was get the party started by Pink
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so clearly the focus group was like no
no no no we're gonna get everybody to
think you're the fun guy
oh this looks good what's this guy the
pink the pink they're good they're
amazing actual top song lists are which
it's too revealing yeah yeah you look at
like what I'm listening to on repeat
that tells you everything you need to
know about me you wouldn't know if every
politician that's in the closet by the
music they listen to I could never be a
politician my favorite band I love
listening to Napalm death and Julie
Andrews
no but that would make you very popular
for being like everybody else yes you
know like Vivek how much how much more
does Eminem have to do to let you know
you can't play his music anymore bro
he's literally said do not play or more
importantly sing my music anymore
so maybe he'll stop but you're that's
the problem I mean this is literally
everyone and I think cat him only having
eight songs makes him realer to me than
the rest because let's be honest when
someone says what's your favorite
top 10 songs you'll get to like seven or
eight and then you're just saying stuff
yeah like you know like you have your
five on rotation you know then you have
one that you forgot about when you hear
like oh that's my jam but you don't
remember that stuff so the fact whoever
hit 20 fake they they were like I'll
pick this one make sure we pick one from
each group to represent to let Americans
know when I play my music I'm thinking
of them it would be so refreshing if the
president was like I'm trying to get
elected I got time for this yeah uh
what's what's on my iPad right now
that's it's whatever's clever you know
I would have if I'm running I would pick
uh Afternoon Delight by the Starland
Vocal Band
do you remember the song Chevy van
thank you 90 year old man over there
and then something weird by I don't know
you're right yeah that's you're right
yeah Andrew
um do you have do would you be able to
do this list or would you actually think
about it before you do the list so that
you could because you want a perception
it's like oh these are the songs I like
but I'm gonna change it because I want
them to think I'm cool which is what
they did yeah I would never be honest uh
same same thing cat said is because I
listen to the Indigo Girls no you don't
I'm like that explains the beard yeah
and exactly exactly and it's funny
because when you made the lesbian joke
about Joe's like you know I mean I'm an
Indigo Girls fan but did you ever go to
the Lilith Fair yeah they'll love the
littlest thing I mean you know love it
absolutely love it um my nickname in
high school was was Melissa Etheridge so
uh but I will say this right I so I went
on Twitter and then I kind of like got
one of these you know crazy hackers to
go in to all of their iPods right how
old am I and get their real list so the
truth behind this is Chris Chris
Christie is Cheeseburger in Paradise yes
okay
um you know and then we've got Ron
DeSantis Bridge Over Troubled Water
um we've got Joe Joe Biden staying alive
uh you know Nick Nikki Haley uh drop a
bomb on me and then obviously Donald
Trump is Jailhouse Rock so you know
let's just let's the truth is the truth
that's funny Joe um I've never hear her
I've never heard you listen to music at
all is music some kind of weird thing
that you don't understand
no Greg I listen to music all the time
it's just I only listen to one song what
is it it's a duet between Neil Diamond
and Barbra Streisand you don't bring me
flowers anymore
[Music]
it combines not wasting money on flowers
with breaking up with Barbra Streisand
but my favorite part about this story
my favorite part about this story is
this is a Fluff piece meant to humanize
the candidates and Mike Pence didn't
participate
[Applause]
Pence would have said something really
creepy like the sound of my wife's voice
is all the music yeah
maybe they picked hanging around by the
stranglers
[Laughter]
too soon
he's a real big DMX guy yeah
Pence and his rendition of Where The
Hood At
all right we got to move on up next a
flyer gets hate for leaving his wife at
the gate hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else